>>> I've been very removed from
celeb gossip.
>> We're not forced to be
informed.
>> Only thing keeping me
informed is the toasters.
>> Kagny and kaudia -- Claudia
oshry.
>> Looking at Jackie and
Claudia, massive social media
empire is getting even bigger.
>> Always been dream to be
morning show hosts but current
day time setup as 24-year-old
woman don't feel represented or
see a show I'm dying to watch.
>> Good morning millennials.
>> Created the morning show we
wished to see in the world.
>> Talk culture on "The morning
toast" on YouTube.
Careers began was social media
influencers.
>> I started to realize this was
real profession in college,
social media marketing.
>> 200,000 Instagram followers,
Claudia's path more unorthodox,
began with bad experience in
fashion.
>> Started a blog called "Girl
with a job," on tumblr.
Just to talk about people I
worked with.
>> Got fired, turned into "Girl
with no jobs."
Big brands love.
>> Fell into meme entertainment
humor content on Instagram and
was on Instagram early and it
became its own brand and
figuring out different ways to
do things with it, like "The
toast".
>> Cover the Kardashians,
housewives and "The bachelor."
>> Very expensive.
>> Been hard on you.
>> More than I realized.
>> Between the two of us operate
a whole business as two people
but very different roles.
I'm standards and hr and setting
the rules and Claudia is the
comedic genius.
>> And their empire is
expanding, there's a podcast and
comedy tour, "The dirty jeans
tour."
>> I'm so afraid to fail.
Had to put up our own money to
start the show and get studio.
Investment keeps me up at night.
Thank god it pays off.
>> Hard work and grit pays off.
>> Stay persistent.
>>> Next up, how much damage did
the college cheating scandal do
to felicity and Lori's careers.
Expert is here, we dig in.